The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Over the past
several lectures, we've
developed a representation for
linear time-invariant systems.
A particularly important set of
systems, which are linear
and time-invariant, are those
that are represented by linear
constant-coefficient
differential equations in
continuous time or linear
constant-coefficient
difference equations
in discrete time.
For example, electrical circuits
that are built, let's
say, out of resistors,
inductors, and capacitors,
perhaps with op-amps, correspond
to systems
described by differential
equations.
Mechanical systems with
springs and dashpots,
likewise, are described by
differential equations.
And in the discrete-time case,
things such as moving average
filters, digital filters, and
most simple kinds of data
smoothing are all linear
constant-coefficient
difference equations.
Now, presumably in a previous
course, you've had some
exposure to differential
equations for continuous time,
and their solution using
notions like particular
solution, and homogeneous
solution, initial
conditions, et cetera.
Later on in the course, when
we've developed the concept of
the Fourier transform after
that, the Laplace transform,
we'll see some very efficient
and useful ways of generating
solutions, both for
differential
and difference equations.
At this point, however, I'd like
to just introduce linear
constant-coefficient
differential equations and
their discrete-time
counterpart.
And address, among other things,
the issue of when they
do and don't correspond to
linear time-invariant systems.
Well, let's first consider
what I refer to as an
nth-order linear
constant-coefficient
differential equation, as
I've indicated here.
And what it consists of is
a linear combination of
derivatives of the system
output, y(t), equal to a
linear combination of
derivatives of the system
input x(t).
And it's referred to as a
constant-coefficient equation,
of course, because the
coefficients are constant.
In other words, not assumed
to be time-varying.
And it's referred to as linear
because it corresponds to a
linear combination of these
derivatives, not because it
corresponds to a
linear system.
And, in fact, as we'll see,
or as I'll indicate, this
equation may or may
not, in fact,
correspond to a linear system.
In the discrete-time case, the
corresponding equation is a
linear constant-coefficient
difference equation.
And that corresponds to, again,
a linear combination of
delayed versions of the output
equal to a linear combination
of delayed versions
of the input.
This equation is referred to an
nth-order difference equation.
The n referring to the number
of delays of the output
involved, just as an Nth-order
differential equation, the n
or the order of the equation
refers to the number of
derivatives of the output.
Now, let's first begin with
linear constant-coefficient
differential equations.
And the basic point of the
solution for the differential
equations is the fact that if
we've generated some solution,
which I refer to here as y_p(t),
some solution to the
equation for a given input,
then, in fact, we can add to
that solution any other solution
which satisfies
what's referred to as the
homogeneous equation.
So in fact, this differential
equation by itself is not a
unique specification
of the system.
If I have any solution, then I
can add to that solution any
other solution which satisfies
the homogeneous equation, and
the sum of those two will
likewise be a solution.
And that's very straightforward
to verify.
By simply substituting into the
differential equation, the
sum of a particular and the
homogeneous solution, and what
you'll see is that the
homogeneous contribution, in
fact, goes to zero by definition
of what we mean by
the homogeneous equation.
Now, the homogeneous solution
for a linear
constant-coefficient
differential equation is of
the form that I indicate
at the bottom.
And it typically consists of a
sum of N complex exponentials.
And the constants are
undetermined by
the equation itself.
And this form for the
homogeneous solution, in
essence, drops out of examining
the homogeneous
equation, where if we assume
that the form of the
homogeneous solution is a
complex exponential with some
unspecified amplitude and
unspecified exponent.
If we substitute this into our
homogeneous equation, we end
up with the equation that
I've indicated here.
The factor A and the e^(st) can
in fact be canceled out,
and we find that that equation
is satisfied
for N values of s.
And that's true no matter what
choice is made for these
coefficients.
And the essential consequence
of all of that is that the
homogeneous solution is of
the form that I indicated
previously.
Namely it consists of a sum of
N complex exponentials, where
the coefficients, the N
coefficients, attach to each
of those complex exponential
is undetermined or
unspecified.
So what this says is that in
order to obtain the solution
for a linear
constant-coefficient
differential equation, we need
some kind of auxiliary
information that tells us
is how to obtain these N
undetermined constants.
And there are variety of ways
of specifying this auxiliary
information or auxiliary
conditions.
For example, in addition to
the differential equation,
what I can tell you is the value
of the output and N - 1
of its derivatives, at some
specified time, t_0.
And so the differential equation
together with the
auxiliary information, the
initial conditions, then lets
you determine the total
solution, which namely lets
you determine these
previously-unspecified
coefficients in the homogeneous
solution.
Now, depending on how the
auxiliary information is
stated or what auxiliary
information is available, the
system may or may not correspond
to a linear system,
and may or may not correspond
to a linear
time-invariant system.
One essential condition for it
to correspond to a linear
system is that the initial
conditions must be 0.
And one can see the reason for
that, if we refer back to the
previous lecture in which we saw
that for a linear system,
if we put 0 in, we get 0 out.
So if x(t), the input, is
0, the output must be 0.
And so that, in essence, tells
us that, at least for the
system to be linear, these
initial conditions must be 0.
Now, beyond that, if we want
the system to be causal and
linear and time-invariant, then
what's required on the
initial conditions is that they
be consistent with what's
referred to as initial rest.
Initial rest says that the
output must be 0 up until the
time that the input
becomes non-zero.
And we can see, of course, that
that's consistent with
the notion of causality,
as we talked about in
the previous lecture.
And it's relatively
straightforward to see that if
the system is causal and linear
and time-invariant,
that will require
initial rest.
It's somewhat more difficult
to see that if we specify
initial rest, then that, in
fact, is sufficient to
determine that the system is
both causal and linear and
time invariant.
But the essential point then
is that it requires initial
rest for both linearity
and causality.
OK, well, let's look at an
example, and let's take the
example of a first-order
differential equation, as I've
indicated here.
So we have a first-order
differential equation, dy(t) /
dt + ay(t) is the input x(t).
And let's first look at what
the homogeneous solution of
this equation is.
And so, we consider the
homogeneous equation, namely
the equation that specifies
solutions, which would
correspond to 0 input.
We, in essence, guess, or impose
a solution of the form.
The homogeneous solution is an
amplitude factor times a
complex exponential.
Substituting this into the
homogeneous equation, we then
get the equation that
I've indicated here.
What you can see is that in this
equation, I can cancel
out the amplitude factor and
this complex exponential.
So let's just cancel those out
on both sides of the equation.
And what we're left with is an
equation that specifies what
the complex exponent must be.
In particular, for the
homogeneous solution, s must
be equal to -a, and so finally,
our homogeneous
solution is as I've
indicated here.
Now, let's look at the solution
for a specific input.
Let's consider, for example,
an input which is
a scaled unit step.
And although I won't work out
the solution in detail and
perhaps using what you've worked
on previously, you know
how to carry out the
solution for that.
A solution with a step input is
what I've indicated here: a
scalar, 1 minus an exponential,
times a unit step.
And you can verify that simply
by substituting into the
differential equation.
Now, we know that there's
a family of solutions.
In other words, any solution
with a homogeneous solution
added to it, is, again,
a solution.
And so if we consider the
solution that I just
indicated, we generate the
entire family of solutions by
adding a homogeneous solution
to it, and so this then
corresponds to the entire family
of solutions, where the
constant A is unspecified so
far, and needs to be specified
through some type of auxiliary
conditions.
Now, a class of auxiliary
conditions is the condition of
initial rest, which as I
indicated before, is
equivalent to the statement that
the system is causal and
linear and time-invariant.
And in that case, for the
initial rest condition, we
would then require in this
equation above that this
constant be equal to 0.
And so finally, the response
to a scaled step--
if the system is to correspond
to a causal linear
time-invariant system, is then
just this term, namely, a
constant times 1 minus an
exponential, times the step.
Now, if the system is a linear
time-invariant system, it can,
as we know, be described through
its impulse response.
And as you've worked out
previously in the video course
manual, for a linear
time-invariant system, the
impulse response is the
derivative of the step response.
And just to quickly remind
you of where that
result comes from.
In essence, we can consider
two linear time-invariant
systems in cascade, one a
differentiator, the other the
system that we're talking
about described by the
differential equation.
And a step in here then
generates an impulse into our
system, and out comes the
impulse response.
Well, just using the fact that
these are both linear
time-invariant systems, and they
can be cascaded in either
order, then means that if we
have the step response to our
system, and that goes through
the differentiator, what must
come out, again, is the
impulse response.
So differentiating the
step response, we
get the impulse response.
Here again, is the step response
as we just worked it
out, this time for
a unit step.
If we differentiate, we have
then, since the step response
is the product of two terms, the
derivative of a product is
the sum of the derivatives.
And carrying that algebra
through, and using the fact
that the derivative of the step
is an impulse, finally we
come down to this statement
for the impulse response.
And then recognizing
that this is a time
function times an impulse.
And we know that if a time
function times an impulse
takes on the value at the time
that the impulse occurs, then
this term is simply 0.
And the impulse response
then finally is an
exponential of this form.
And this is the decaying
exponential for a-positive,
it's a growing exponential
for a-negative.
And recall that, as we talked
about previously, a linear
time-invariant system is stable
if its impulse response
is absolutely integrable.
For this particular case, this
impulse response is absolutely
integrable provided that the
exponential factor a is
greater than 0.
Okay, so what we've seen then is
the impulse response for a
system described by a linear
constant-coefficient
differential equation, where in
addition, we would impose
causality, linearity, and
time-invariance, essentially,
through the initial conditions
of initial rest.
Now, pretty much the same kinds
of things happen with
difference equations as we've
gone through with
differential equations.
In particular, again, let me
remind you of the form of an
Nth order linear constant
coefficient difference equation.
It's as I indicate here.
And, again, a linear
combination, this time of
delayed versions of the output
equal to a linear combination
of delayed versions
of the input.
Once again, difference equation
is not a complete
specification of the system
because we can add to the
response any homogeneous
solution.
In other words, any solution
that satisfies the homogeneous
equation and the sum of those
will also satisfy the original
difference equation.
So if we have a particular
response that satisfies the
difference equation, then adding
to that any response
that is a solution to the
homogeneous equation will also
be a solution to the
total equation.
The homogeneous solution, again,
is of the form of a
linear combination
of exponentials.
Here, we have the homogeneous
equation.
As with differential equations,
we can guess or
impose solutions of the form
A times an exponential.
When we substitute this into the
homogeneous equation, we
then end up with the equation
that I've indicated here.
We recognize again that A, the
amplitude, and z^n, this
exponential factor,
cancel out.
And so this equation is
satisfied for any values of z
that satisfy this equation.
And there are N roots,
z_1 through z_N.
And so finally, the form for the
homogeneous solution is a
linear combination of capital N
exponentials, where capital
N is the order of
the equation.
With each of those exponentials,
the amplitude
factor is undetermined and needs
to be determined in some
way through the imposition of
appropriate initial conditions
or boundary conditions.
So the general form then for the
solution to the difference
equation is a sum of
exponentials plus any
particular solution.
It's through auxiliary
conditions that we determine
these coefficients.
We have N undetermined
coefficients and, so we
require N auxiliary
conditions.
For example, some set of values
of the output at N
distinct instance of time.
Now this was the same as with
differential equations.
In the case of differential
equations, we talked about
specifying the value of the
output and its derivatives.
And there, we indicated
that for
linearity, what we required--
for linearity, what we required
is that the auxiliary
conditions be 0.
And the same thing applies
here for the same reason.
Namely, if the system is to be
linear, then the response, if
there's no input, must
be equal to 0.
In addition, what we may want
to impose on the system is
that it be causal, and
in addition to linear
time-invariant, and what that
requires, again, is that the
auxiliary conditions be
consistent with initial rest,
namely, that if the input is 0
prior to some time, then the
output is 0 prior to
the same time.
So we've seen a very direct
parallel so far between
differential equations and
difference equations.
In fact, one difference between
them that, in some
sense, makes difference
equations easier to deal with
in some situations, is that in
contrast to a differential
equation, a difference equation,
if we assume
causality, in fact is an
explicit input-output
relationship for the system.
Now, let me show you
what I mean.
Let's consider the nth-order
difference equation, as I've
indicated here.
And let's assume that we're
imposing causality so that the
output can only depend on prior
values of the input, and
therefore, aren't prior
values of the output.
Well, we can simply rearrange
this equation solving for y[n]
the leading term, with k = 0.
Taking all of the other terms
over to the right side of the
equation, and we then have a
recursive equation, namely, an
equation that expresses the
output in terms of prior
values of the input, which is
this term, and prior values of
the output.
And so if, in fact, we have this
equation running, then
once it started, we know how to
compute the output for the
next time instant.
Well, how do we get
it started?
The way we get it started,
of course, is through the
appropriate set of initial
conditions or boundary
conditions.
And, if for example, we assume
initial rest corresponding to
a causal linear time-invariant
system, then if the input is 0
up until some time, the output
must be 0 up until that time.
And that, in essence, helps us
get the equation started.
Well, let's look at this
specifically in the context of
a first-order difference
equation.
So let's take a first-order
difference equation, as I've
indicated here.
And so, we have an equation
that tells us that y[n]
- ay[n-1]
= x[n].
Now, if we want this to
correspond to a causal linear
time-invariant system, we impose
initial rest on it.
We can rewrite the first-order
difference equation by taking
the term involving y[n-1]
over two the right hand
side of the equation.
Now, this gives us a recursive
equation that expresses the
output in terms of the input and
past values of the output.
And since we've imposed
causality, and if we're
talking about a linear
time-invariant system, we can
now inquire as to what the
impulse response is.
And we know, of course, the
impulse response tells us
everything that we need to
know about the system.
So let's choose an input,
which is an impulse.
So the impulse response
is delta[n]
corresponding to the x[n]
up here, plus a delta of--
this should be h[n-1].
And let me just correct that.
This is h[n-1].
So we have the impulse
response as delta[n]
plus a times h[n-1].
Now, from initial rest, we know
that since the input,
namely an impulse, is 0 for
n less than 0, the impulse
response is likewise 0
for n less than 0.
And now, let's work
out what h[0]
is.
Well, h of 0, with n
= 0, is delta[0]
plus a times h[n-1].
h[n-1]
is 0.
And so, h[0]
is equal to 1.
Now that we have h[0], we
can figure out h[1]
by running this recursive
equation.
So h[1]
is delta[1], which is 0, plus
a times h[0], which we just
figured out is 1.
So, h[1]
is equal to a.
And if we carry this through,
we'll have h[2]
equal to a^2, and this
will continue on.
And in fact, what we can
recognize by looking at this
and how we would expect these
terms to build, we would see
that the impulse response, h[n],
in fact, is of the form
a^n times u[n].
And we also can recognize then
that this corresponds to a
stable system, if and only if
the impulse response, which is
what we just figured out, if
and only if the impulse
response is absolutely
summable.
And what that will require is
that the magnitude of a be
less than 1.
Now, we imposed causality,
linearity, and
time-invariance, and generated
a solution recursively.
And now, of course, if we want
to generate the more general
set of solutions to this
difference equation, we can do
that by adding all of the
homogeneous solutions, namely,
all the solutions that satisfy
the homogeneous equation.
So here, we have the
causal linear
time-invariant impulse response.
In fact, with an impulse input,
all of the possible
solutions are that impulse
response plus
the homogeneous solutions.
The homogeneous solution is the
solution that satisfies
the homogeneous equation.
That will, in general, be of the
form an amplitude factor
times an exponential factor, and
if we substitute this into
this equation, then we see that
the homogeneous equation
is satisfied for any values of
a and any values of z that
satisfy this equation.
Again, as we did with
differential equations, the
factor A cancels out.
And also, in fact, I can
cancel out a z^n
there and a z^n here.
And so what we're left with is a
statement that tells us then
that the homogeneous solution is
of the form a(z^n), for any
value of A and any value of z
that satisfies this equation.
And that value of z, in
particular, is z equal to a.
So the homogeneous solution
then is any exponential of
this form with any
amplitude factor.
And so, the family of solutions,
with an impulse
input is the solution
corresponding to the system
being causal, linear, and
time-invariant, plus the
homogeneous term.
If we impose causality,
linearity, and time-invariance
on the system, then of course,
that additional exponential
factor will be 0.
In other words, A
is equal to 0.
Now, we've seen the differential
equations and
difference equations in terms
of the fact that there are
families of solutions, and in
order to get causality,
linearity, and time-invariance
requires imposing a particular
set of initial conditions,
namely, imposing initial rest
on the system.
Let's now look at the difference
equation and then
later, the differential
equation, interpreted in block
diagram terms.
Now, the difference equation,
as I just simply repeated
here, is y[n]
= x[n]
+ ay[n-1], where I've taken the
delayed term over to the
right hand side of
the equation.
So, in effect, what
I'm imposing on
this system is causality.
I'm assuming that if I know the
past history of the input
and the output, I can determine
the next value of
the output.
Well, we can, in fact, draw a
block diagram that represents
that equation.
The equations says,
we take x[n]
for any given value of n, say
n0, whatever value we're
computing the output for.
We take the input at that time,
and add to it the factor
a times the output value that
we calculated last time.
So if we have x[n], which is
our input, and if we have
y[n], which is our output, we,
in fact, can get y of n by
taking the last value of y[n],
indicated here by putting y[n]
through a delay, multiplying
that by the factor a, and then
adding that result
to the input.
And the result of doing
that is y[n].
So the way this block diagram
might be interpreted, for
example, as an algorithm is to
say that we take x[n], add to
it a times the previous
value the output.
That sum gives us the current
value of the output, which we
then put out of the system,
and also put into a delay
element, or basically, into a
storage register, to use on
the next iteration
or recursion.
Now, how do we get
this started?
Well, we know that the
difference equation requires
initial conditions.
And, in fact, the initial
conditions correspond to what
we store in the delay register
when this block diagram or
equation initially starts up.
OK Now, let's look at this for
the case of difference
equations more generally.
So, what we've said is that we
can calculate the output by
having previous values of the
input, previous values of the
output, and forming the
appropriate linear
combination.
So let's just build up the more
general block diagram
that would correspond to this.
And what it says is that we want
to have a mechanism for
storing past values of the
input, and a mechanism for
storing past values
of the output.
And I've indicated that on
this figure, so far, by a
chain of delay elements,
indicating that what the
output of each delay is, is the
input delayed by one time
instant or interval.
And so what we see down this
chain of delays are delayed
replications of the input.
And what we see on the other
chain is delayed replications
of the output.
Now, the difference equation
says that we want to take
these, and multiply them by the
appropriate coefficients,
the coefficients in the
difference equation, and so,
we can do that as I've
indicated here.
So now, we have these delay
elements, each multiplied by
the appropriate coefficients
on the input, and by
appropriate coefficients
on the output.
Those are then summed together,
and so we now will
sum these and will sum these.
After we've summed these, we
want to add those together.
And there's a factor of
1 / a_0 that comes in.
And so that then generates
our output.
And so this, in fact, then
represents a block diagram,
which is a general block diagram
for implementing or
representing a linear
constant-coefficient
difference equation.
Now, if you think about what
it means in terms of, let's
say, a computer algorithm or a
piece of hardware, in fact,
this block diagram is a recipe
or algorithm for doing the
implementation.
But it's important to recognize,
even at this point,
that it's only one of many
possible algorithms or
implementations for this
difference equation.
Just for example, I can consider
that equation for
that block diagram.
And here, I've re-drawn it.
So here, are once again.
I have the same block diagram
that we just saw.
And I can recognize, for
example, that this, in
essence, corresponds to two
linear time-invariant systems
in cascade.
Now, that assumes, of course,
that my initial conditions are
such that the system is,
in fact, linear.
And that, in turn, requires that
we're assuming initial
rests, namely, before
the input does
anything other than 0.
There are just 0 values stored
in the registers.
But assuming that it corresponds
to a linear
time-invariant system, this
is a cascade of two linear
time-invariant invriant
systems.
We know that two linear
time-invariant systems can be
cascaded in either order.
So, in particular, I can
consider breaking this cascade
here, and moving this block
over to the other side.
And so let's just do that.
And when I do, I then have this
combination of systems,
and, of course, you can ask
what advantage there is to
doing that, and the advantage
arises because of the fact
that in this form, exactly what
is stored in these delays
is also stored in these
delay registers.
In other words, it's this
intermediate variable--
whatever it is--
down this chain of the delays
and down this chain of delays,
and so, in fact, I can collapse
those delays into a
single chain of delays.
And the network that I'm left
with is the network that I
indicate on this view graph,
where what I've done is to
simply collapse that double
chain of delays into a single
change of delays.
Now, one can ask, well, what's
the advantage to doing that?
And one advantage, simply
stated, is that when you think
in terms of an implementation
of a difference equation, a
delay corresponds to a storage
register, a memory location,
and by simply using the fact
that we can interchange the
order in which linear
time-invariant systems are
cascaded, we can reduce
the amount of memory
by a factor of 2.
Now, an essentially similar
procedure can also be used for
differential equations, in terms
of implementation using
block diagrams or the
interpretation of
implementations using
block diagrams.
And let me first do that--
rather than in general-- let me
first do it in the context
of a specific example.
So let's consider a linear
constant-coefficient
differential equation, as I've
indicated here, and I have
terms on the left side and
terms on the right side.
And with the differential
equation, let's consider
taking all the terms over
to the right side of the
equation, except
for the highest
derivative in the output.
Next, we integrate both sides
of the equation so that when
we're done, we end up with
on the left side of the
equation with y(t).
On the right side of the
equation with the appropriate
number of integrations.
And so the integral equation
that we'll get for this
example y(t), the output, is
x(t) plus b, the scale factor
times the integral of the input,
and minus a, that scale
factor, times the integral
of the output.
So to form the output in the
block diagram terms, we form a
linear combination of the input,
a scaled integral of
the input, and a scaled integral
of the output, all of
that added together.
So we need, in addition to
the input, we need the
integral of the input.
And so this box indicates
an integrator.
In addition to the output,
we need the
integral of the output.
And now, to form y(t), we
multiply the integrated input
by the scale factor, b.
And add that to x(t), and we
take the integrated output,
multiply it by -a, and add
to that the result of the
previous addition, and according
to the integral
equation, then that
forms the output.
So just as we did with the
difference equation, we've
converted the differential
equation to an integral
equation, and we have a block
diagram form very similar to
what we had in the case of
the difference equation.
Now, the initial conditions,
of course, are tied up in,
again, how these integrators
are initialized.
Assuming that we impose initial
rest on the system, we
can think of the overall
system as a linear
time-invariant system, and it's
a cascade of one linear
time-invariant system
with a second.
So we can, in fact, break
this, and consider
interchanging the order
in which these
two systems are cascaded.
And so I've indicated
that down below.
Here, I've simply taken
the top block diagram,
interchanged the order
in which the
two systems are cascaded.
And here, again, we can ask what
the advantages to this,
as opposed to the
previous one.
And what you can see, just as
we saw with the difference
equation, is that now,
the integrators--
both integrators--
are integrating the
same thing.
In particular, the input to this
integrator and the input
to this integrator
are identical.
So in fact, rather than using
this one, we can simply tap
off from here.
We can, in fact, remove this
integrator, break this
connection, and tap
in at this point.
And so what we've done then, by
interchanging the order in
which the systems are cascaded,
is reduced the
implementation to the
implementation with a single
integrator.
Very much similar to what we
talked about in the case of
the difference equation.
Now, let's just, again, with the
integral equation or the
differential equation, look at
this somewhat more generally.
Again, if we take the
differential equation, the
general differential equation,
integrate it a sufficient
number of times to convert it
to an integral equation.
We would then have this
cascade of systems.
And again, if we assume initial
rest, so that these
are both linear time-invariant
systems, we can interchange
the order in which
they're cascaded.
Namely, take the second system,
and move it to precede
the first system.
And then what we recognize is
that the input to this chain
of integrators and this
chain of integrators
is exactly the same.
And so, in fact we can collapse
these together using
only one chain of integrators.
And the system that we're left
with then is a system that
looks as I've indicated here.
So we have now just a single
chains of integrators instead
of the two sets of
integrators.
So we've seen that the situation
is very similar here
as it was in the case of the
difference equation.
Again, why do we want
to cut the number of
integrators in half?
Well, one reason is because
integrators, in effect,
represent hardware.
And if we have half as many
integrators, then we're using
half as much hardware.
Well, let me just conclude by
summarizing a number of points.
I indicated at the beginning
that linear
constant-coefficient
differential equations and
difference equations will play
an important role as linear
time-invariant systems
throughout this course and
throughout this set
of lectures.
I also stressed the fact that
differential or difference
equations, by themselves, are
not a complete specification
of the system because of the
fact that we can add to any
solution a homogeneous
solution.
How do we specify the
appropriate initial conditions
to ensure--
how do we specify the
appropriate initial conditions
to ensure that the system is
linear and time-invariant?
Well, the auxiliary information,
namely, the
initial conditions associated
with the system being causal,
linear, and time-invariant
are the
conditions of initial rest.
And, in fact, for most of the
course, what we'll be
interested in are systems that
are in fact, causal, linear,
and time-invariant.
And so we will, in fact, be
assuming initial rest
conditions.
Now, as I also indicated,
there are a variety of
efficient procedures for solving
differential and
difference equations that we
haven't yet addressed.
And beginning with the next
set of lectures, we'll be
talking about the Fourier
Transform and much later in
the course, what's referred to
as the Laplace Transform for
continuous time and the
Z-transform for discrete time.
And what we'll see is that with
the Fourier Transform and
later with the Laplace and
Z-transform, we'll have a
number of efficient and very
useful ways of generating the
solution for differential and
difference equations under the
assumption that the system
is causal, linear, and
time-invariant.
Also, we'll see in addition
to the block diagram
implementations of these systems
that we've talked
about so far, we'll see a
number of other useful
implementations that exploit
a variety of properties
associated with Fourier and
Laplace Transforms.
Thank you.